This one thing completely revolutionized
my flow. It changed the way I think
about transitions, about writing poi
phrases in general, and I think that it
made my flow much more smooth. So, what
was it? I'm going to share it with you
in this video.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I am going to
let you in on a tip-top secret that is
going to revolutionize the way that you
spin. At least it did for me. But before
we dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parer, Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-B business friend of
the channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you
so very much for supporting my channel,
my work, and my mission. So, I'm going
to start this off by explaining what I
think of as the Lego theory of poi
transitions. And more than likely, you
have used this without even knowing it.
Basically, it breaks down as such. So,
when we get into poi, there are a whole
host of movements out there that we can
do with the poi, but we want to kind of
narrow our focus a bit. So, we look at
patterns of movements that are easily
repeatable and have a really distinctive
appearance, and we just kind of
arbitrarily put a bracket around them
and refer to them as tricks. There's
nothing intrinsically that makes that
series of movements into say a butterfly
or a weave. But because it's something
easy for us to wrap our heads around,
that's the label that we apply to it.
When we first start off learning PO
tricks, we learn this trick, that trick,
this trick, that trick. Maybe it's
reels, butterflies, weaves, windmills,
and a whole host of others. And because
we learn all these poi moves in this
kind of arbitrarily bracketed fashion,
we also get to thinking of them as
individual islands. They're just kind of
isolated from each other in space rather
than movements that say repeat here or
repeat here or repeat here rather than
continuing on to another move. And this
means that transitioning between them
winds up becoming a lot more difficult
than it needs to be. So basically, when
we're first learning poi, it's like
we're acquiring individual Lego blocks
and we're looking for a way to put them
together. And because we're so used to
seeing poi in terms of those blocks, we
also get to thinking about the
transitions between the tricks as unique
blocks in and of themselves. So to give
you an example of this in action, let's
say I want to put together three unique
PO tricks. That is a windmill, a weave,
and a butterfly. Now the way I can do
this is I'll say start off with my
windmill here. And when I want to switch
into my waist strap, that's going to
involve me taking the PO down to the
side and specifically looking for a
moment coming out of the windmill when I
can get my left hand under my right in
that weave. From here, I will perform a
pendulum with my right hand under my
left. And that switches the direction of
my right hand po to get into a
butterfly. So, we've essentially just
put together five specific Lego bricks.
We have our windmill that we attach to
our waist strap via a level change. And
we have our waist straps connecting onto
our butterflies via a pendulum. So,
we've got a total of five blocks there
that are all stacked together. And it
does need to be said, this approach
absolutely works. It worked for me when
I was first starting out, and it's
worked for countless other PO spinners
all over the world. But I do have to say
that because it involves learning poi in
such a modular fashion, there's also
something about it that just looks a
little bit mechanical to me. So, is
there an alternative? Why yes, indeed
there is. So, as an alternative to the
Lego approach of putting together a PO
combo, I've come up with something that
I think of as the road trip approach.
So, the road trip approach basically
looks like this. Rather than thinking
about individual tricks or transitions
as being specific Lego blocks that I'm
trying to put together in the right
order, instead I'm thinking about the
entire combo as something like a road
trip. Namely, I have a start and I have
a destination that I'm intending to get
to. And along the way, rather than
stacking together tricks and transitions
in the proper order, I'm instead
thinking of them as just being points
that I pass through on my way to my
final destination. And sometimes I
notice different things along the road.
Perhaps one trick this particular time,
another trick another time. It all
depends. But the long and short of it is
to think of the combo itself as being
one holistic unit rather than a series
of blocks that have to be put together.
So to see this in action, I am actually
going to take that exact same combo that
we played with earlier, going between
windmills and waist straps and
butterflies, and I'm going to look at it
through this lens. So rather than trying
to just connect the dots, I'm instead
gonna think that I want to start off on
stage right, build up some momentum,
take it around, and change that momentum
to a place where I come back to rest.
See, what I'm doing here is not just
adding dance or body movement to it. I'm
really thinking about how exactly am I
going to get to my end point here. Where
do I increase energy and where do I take
it away? And how do I add drama and
suspense to it? And it should be pointed
out here that I can do this exact same
idea but with completely different
tricks. Let's say instead I'm feeling
doing some tuck turns. So I'm going to
go ahead and start off building up some
momentum and boom, take them around and
then coming into a flower on the other
side. Same kind of thing. I'm starting
in a particular place. I'm trying to get
to another. And in the meantime, I just
happen to be posting up specific road
signs. Sometimes those correspond to
things that we would recognize as tricks
and sometimes they don't. So, how
exactly do you learn the road trip
approach to performing PO combos? Well,
here are three ideas that might get you
started on it. First and foremost, start
by visualizing your combo. Not in terms
of the tricks that you intend to use,
but in terms of where the energy levels
go up and where they come back down. And
just remember, when you're taking a road
trip, that doesn't necessarily mean that
the road is always perfectly straight.
As you saw with the combo I just did,
sometimes the road can take a hard right
turn and take you in a direction you
might not have originally anticipated.
Think about points that you'd like to
read as a climax and recognize that you
have access to tools such as volume and
level changes as well as speed changes
to make that read to your audience. And
in order to find calm in between those
climaxes, you have to return back down
to a baseline level. Think that when
you're performing your combo, it's
almost like a roller coaster being
pushed up to a point where it has a lot
of potential energy and then letting it
go in a wild ride before finally finding
its way back to rest. Tip number two,
break out of the box. If you want to add
and remove momentum, you have to start
moving your feet and moving around on
stage. Think not just about how you can
add energy with the poi, but also with
your entire body, expanding outward,
contracting, turning, moving from place
to place. There's nothing saying that
you can't find stillness every so often.
That's good for building up tension and
or finding rest at the end of a phrase,
but it shouldn't be your only option
here. Explore. Tip number three, shift
your thinking. They are not transitions.
They are energy changes. Does that
energy change mean the level of the po
changes? Does it mean that one of the po
changes direction? How exactly do you
get to that energy change? And what does
it do for the combo? That is going to
help you on your way. And above all
else, have fun with it. The whole point
of this is to break you out of a
traditional way of thinking and bring up
something that gives you more freedom.
So go out and have fun with it and let
me know how it works for you. If you got
anything out of this video, please make
sure to like, share, comment, and
subscribe to help other people find it
and of course to help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. And if you out there would like to
get your name in the credits or access
to any other of a host of awesome
rewards, you can go sign up for my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
Go check it out. I'll leave a link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. Thank you in advance. And if
you'd like to learn some ways that you
can put together po tricks with basic
dance steps, I did a series of videos on
those that I will link to in a playlist
up on screen as well as down in the
description. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out in the
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon. Take care. Peace.